hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to drunk minecraft with
bobbing waves whoa jeez oh yeah they
kill those times are we allowed to drink
now
yes been doing I've already but usually
we do like a drinking thing is there
anything about this series that has a
strict pattern arc we have very strict
flatlines oh wow just wait till we
finish this story arc in our 150 part
series what it all comes together
everyone is just gonna [ __ ] their pants
all at once they won't get used you're
never gonna see it coming cuz the last
episodes just the brown note for 30
minutes that's that's the thing that
ties all of our story arcs together whoo
the fact that the fact that the last
episode will make everyone poop yeah oh
boy that's what we do so how you doing
Wade I'm good you're drinking your
Everclear I'm drinking on the Hornsby
and then Molly made me a concoction to
drink after that so I guess I'll take a
sip of that please drink that one is
that a cider the Hornsby is the other
thing I have no idea what it is well I
was only asking what the Hornsby was oh
oh my god was a good good way really
good oh it sounds good I wish I could
see your face we need to come up over
the way we actually see webcams you can
see you're editing I know but it's not
the same I want to I wanna I want to be
close to you we could all and you could
just do a screen capture of our faces on
Skype call Oh God our bandwidth is bad
enough as it is we couldn't handle that
I'm pretty sure my internet could handle
that down boy alcohol with more alcohol
no I haven't upgraded it it's uh it's
just quality internet mark oh yeah not a
semi an Internet oh look that's not even
the joke
what what is it what opiate Oh like
Eastern European country oh okay so I
probably talk Internet
okay my dad I'm sorry to all my
Lithuanian vans and and Bob's not sorry
to our all our Ethiopian fans hey
correct me if I'm wrong people for me
okay I'm sure that you have horrible
internet and it's not your fault it's
Time Warner's fault yeah [ __ ] it in Time
Warner Ethiopia it's with the bull okay
anyway any area of Time Warner USA yes
can you just shut up and keep drinking
you're not nearly drunk enough none of
us are I think we need to do our
celebratory traditional drinking to the
start of the episode Bob what's the
traditional think is my beers almost
gone do I need more than we just drink a
lot because this is the first time we're
starting to record well wait are you
drinking whoa whoa where did those come
from did we build those no something
that we would build well what in the
world is going on I'm the king of
Colonel Sanders well then how do you
like me now you're not you're not on
Colonel Sanders anymore he died Oh
Sanders giant Medusa came by and flashed
them all with her tits oh thanks yeah
that's a little bit oh did I mention
that my drink is very dangerous I don't
think I mentioned it on camera
I've got Malibu orange cream liqueur and
I mixed it with orange cream soda I
filled this about halfway up with rum
nut liqueur but rum it is I don't even
taste alcohol anymore but I feel it now
so it's good that's good stuff okay so
wait what are we doing I don't know
drinking about something I don't want to
drink this one again what we gonna do
Rincon weren't we gonna make this
episode about pop culture wasn't that
the idea
no I think one of you came up with the
idea that you wanted to make it about
Ebola I recall that in the rejected idea
box because that's horrible
don't agree I don't recall that
happening all right then fine fine
whatever we were gonna be doing and why
these taxes are here is because we're
gonna make the cast's of five nights at
freddys and not do anything horrible
that's gonna offend everybody to them
probably so remember chicas really
[ __ ] yes apparently chica really turns
like 15 no no no unless she does you
know it's her choice you know or well
you know it's really empowering for
women to be [ __ ] so that's a good thing
whoa were you amazed at your own
offensive joke no I was amazed at the
physics that just occurred in front of
my face yeah my joke
my joke was secretly pro-feminist it was
just it was sarcasm I know it was
ostensibly sexist you know the internet
is still are you saying watch this are
not smart enough to understand my humor
mark cuz that's condescending oh that is
rebuilding itself yeah that's what
happened to me the statues that are
magically
don't we have that thing on the thing
where we're doing the thing do the thing
I have no idea cuz we have the zombie
nose yes yes mark yes we have that thing
exactly remember on that first episode
that didn't get released because I'm an
idiot
and what no Wade's an idiot stop stop
stop it
bye you suck god it's been so long since
we actually played Minecraft like silly
Lili oh you're gonna dork okay Wade is
building Bonnie a visor shape it
destroys its heels it's if it does the
thing to itself I don't know it seems to
go find so far it's hurt my knee or two
as you yeah John Connor to me no that's
not that's not right that's not right
John Connor man John Connor going John
okay I can't do Baltimore
actually I imagine I'm sorry oh man that
was beautiful
mmm you're welcome you oh no not you Bob
wait your impression skill thank you Oh
much better over the PAL YC we've been
doing this
whoo what am i building what am i doing
Ricky that Jesus I'm building Freddy
fazbear right yeah he's a bear okay he's
really I know he laughs a lot to see
like a happy bear happy to you that's
pretty happy it's not his fault he has a
weird laugh mark oh they say that it
might be him crying that's like a thing
yeah that's I've heard that rumor yeah
it's the Kissel's of the damn children
with in his belly crying out for their
mamas no one had a really deep voices
I'm just saying yeah exactly you know I
got lots of compliments about my grave
Wow wait that's looking good actually
thank you lots of compliments about my
great voice when I was on that she was
Felicia Day and keen Micucci and all the
other really okay I don't know who came
to coochie is that sounds like bragging
to you I have no idea who that is
she was if you remember from Scrubs
that's where i or if scrubs way way way
back when or towards the end of the
season she was the one that was dating
the lawyer dude when when and she played
the ukulele that was her I don't
remember that you don't remember that
okay absolutely not no why not I didn't
watch scrubs very much I've only seen
like I've seen like the first five
seasons maybe I am I haven't not seen
scrubs but I have not watched all of it
and I definitely didn't watch it after
scrubs and black scrubs were the
teachers or whatever and it got all
stupid yeah
got a little a little weird there's
going I think is there a blood mod where
I could make my bunny bloody uh you can
put Red Bull there cuz this is minecraft
in this guy's limitations yeah Red Bull
Red Bull this blood wave and Red Bulls
you gives you blood oh this is such a
good form to talk about this did you
guys know that you can get free Red Bull
right now if you bought any Red Bull in
like the last six or something cuz I
guess soon oh yeah they got sued in a
class action to apparently everyone in
existence and somehow they lost and you
don't even have to have proof of
purchase you could just say like oh yeah
I bought Red Bull and they're just like
okay have some red bowl I guess really
yes no no dad easy there is no proof of
purchase requirement or anything you
just say that you bought Red Bull and
you can have Red Bull well that's
awfully I thought at least 10 cans a day
because we love the delicious taste of
Red Bull here at markiplier and Friends
we are big sewers the Red Bull please
give us money looks like a pair that's
what bears look like right
we built smoky Oh hard not to recreate
our sake there right now Oh God we're
gonna have we're gonna have a Freddie
three currents what does it mean what a
big word zero give Freddie a penis
Freddie a swastika your mouth there
chica well why don't you and I just
start our own drug Minecraft and not
invite Morgan hookers
yeah drunk minecraft yeah yeah that
thing from that quote from that thing it
TV quote screwed up oh no I do something
what'd you do oh I have no idea how to
make a
in Minecraft so this is how it's gonna
work I didn't need help early you did
need help it's weird
Thanks zombie feel free to help me I'm
not a douchebag I'm very grateful okay
I'll help you thank you no no no no
thank you
I know how to make stuff and out while I
already messed up but that's alright so
I won't help fine it don't matter anyone
help I won't help hey I got help
yay oh [ __ ] whoa help is the number one
cause of help of death in hell most
certainly not oh wait is not a doctor
and is not endorsed to anything so I I'm
your professor well you've had like two
sips you cannot be drunk yet funny I'm
not drunk you sounded drunk
well I laughed those are shitty years
hey don't judge them oh you care cuz I
got big bunny ears and you don't look
how oh well easy easy where the penis is
their penis man your penis man as you
can see I'm working on your own right
over here
eNOS man I am yes thank you for noticing
you like it no mercy
if you don't mind me saying so what else
and I'm done I think is there any other
distinguishing characteristic of Freddie
he's got a microphone and a bowtie and a
top hat and a microphone a yeah he does
yes top hat and a top hat how am I
supposed to make a top hat oh do is it
why are you being so
why I gotta be so rude
I got Mary anyway go to references I
have to say the first time I heard that
song I was like holy [ __ ] this dude is
being really [ __ ] offensive right
here he was all like I don't care if she
says she doesn't want to marry me I'm
gonna marry her anyway oh yeah yeah
looks awful I can't I built here am I in
the spawn right now what's that though I
have some weird things like that - is
that a microphone no well yes it's kind
of a mace microphone for bludgeoning
blowing happiness into all the shit's
Bob Barker's microphone hello long and
slender remember spay and neuter your
pets I hope they'll give you can we get
bug fan art of Bob as Bob Barker I don't
know I make so many Bob Barker
references you're right it's almost like
the price is good [ __ ] that's why I
that's why I make the big YouTube books
why you make all them big fake dollars
how the Internet money that funnels into
my pocket hey funnel some Internet's
stuff my way no oh maybe I just winked
really creepily don't wink ever I wish
this show was also sponsored by audible
like left out like everyone else on the
Internet is sponsored by audible yeah
what is with that eye I think Amazon
should throw us some audible money I
don't think any inspire people to want
to read books don't wait yeah I think we
do that's not what audible if you're
watching a good episode of drunk
minecraft don't you guys want to go out
there and just read a book yeah we
inspire people to not want to read books
which is exactly audibles business did
you literally just remake me as the
chicken what have you made statues of me
please a chicken it's just cuz there's
an enormous penis wait don't don't fool
yourself I think I'm pretty much well no
I got I got one thing I need to fix I
signed up this is gonna be the single
greatest top hat in the history of top
hat so you guys just wait and see
uh-huh well I'm C gonna be fantastical
but I can't guarantee I'll wait I may
have worked myself into a corner enos
corner yeah my whole design seems
awfully penile just sayin it's like it
was mandated by the penal code on our
humor is reaching astronomical levels we
have really matured what the hell the
big droopy dick straight out from the
crotch how do you know it's what it is
let makes you think that
no one's gonna be confused about what it
is is still possibly gonna be the best
one of these so I thought I was in
trouble but I'm really I'm really
cooking with gas here it's pretty naked
why is Freddie naked yeah why is it
black
I'm working on he doesn't have clothes
you said here's a top hat and a
microphone
you don't know Freddie okay let's just
say that you don't even apparently the
only super who hasn't played that games
the LSU wonder in the whole world
need help with its genitalia no oh yes
please assist me on chicas boob the
penis what what are you doing I gotta
give it a tip oh yeah you're right
you're right when you're right you're
right he's a good waiter he needed a
good
wait wait you wanna punch me in the face
it's Wade literally I'm not a jingle
writer but you get what I'm going for
well you have your own jingle for
yourself that we came up with on skate
three all right so it's a microphone and
oh my god okay well Freddie Freddie's
looking at what's coming to his face if
you know what I mean oh I don't want any
penises on my bear I don't need any
penises on my bear he's good there Oh
Izzy though Bob is he a good bear carrot
oh God Oh No wait he diverted it with
his mind powers Bob ready Freddy has my
powers what do you put a peanut penile
blocker
oh you can't you can't defend yourself
from what's about to happen when it's
happening Wade yeah Bob that's enough
that's enough that's a taste like
I like now the only one with nipples is
the only one that's most certainly a guy
the one that we're gonna have piled
animal nipples oh oh like a bear would
oh that's not that's not the right
spacing for bear nipples excuse me a
little bit much for my taste and he's
got like a little scraggly nipple like
right there yeah vii nipple the weird
one it's got a mysterious seventh nipple
yeah it's it's not right you know a lot
of people don't know it but they have a
vestigial third nipple I'm not alone I'm
not making that up it's true that's how
many people like a lot
Oh like a lot yeah can we get exact
numbers for your approximation that's
not the hundred thousand percent of
people have a third nipple that would
mean that everyone has 16 nipples
examine yourselves and count all 16 oh
wait no sorry 1818 nipples man your
picture is the markup 5,000 percent
would mean 180 nipples of Percy good God
send your quarter shop start arriving
your actual pictures of yourself a 65
nipples the markiplier oh I'm getting
girlfriend applications from one episode
like fifty episodes ago if you didn't
know funny that you mentioned that I
actually got a girlfriend application to
forward to you the other day please read
it to me I may have deleted it make it
up then make it up make it up dear
markiplier I think it's really funny
when you scream like a [ __ ] please make
me have all the babies except we don't
want to have babies so let's not do that
love Jessie Fishbach get it oh you
I get it I get it well that's
approximately what it said all right
back
fear future wife that's the Fishbach
Jessie Fishbach we need to talk about
the no babies thing because as you know
I want a big family not a lot just big
are you a professional bodybuilder like
big people here you must be okay
no it's fine it's fine Bob those are the
fire that aren't gonna burn everything
down okay sure
I'm pretty sure I'm not 100% but I think
one out already I'm pretty sure that was
zombies doing anyway lastly almost done
with this episode we've been recording
for 24 minutes and we have some
beautiful credible we lot pan back to
appreciate might die of the situation
mine looks exactly like a bear with the
top hat and a microphone does it look
exactly like the bunny
see also have a bow tie does mine not
look like the sex symbol of the internet
that what you get this day it says let's
and it's an arrow pointing can we make a
really horrifying thumbnail and just
call this five nights at Freddy's
minecraft the people are really is LED
oh yes a bowtie that looks like a
dumbbell on this episode definitely has
to be minecraft five nights at Freddy's
oh yeah oh oh yeah so totally mislead
everyone cuz everyone loves five nights
at Freddy's they do also they'll get
like a Brazilian views oh virgilian Wow
for the next one
now let's blow these devil creatures
back to the house
they crawled out of so that we can move
on with our lives and forget they every
house mine is perfectly nice I don't see
what's mine is really nice oh I like the
three white guys off to the right is two
in there hey if white guys be chillin
what's wrong with white guys yeah let's
do what do you got from I don't know
there no one likes them there now
now he's goofy oh wait was that just
racist to go those races oh no those
super I don't know what it was Tommy
blow it up why does your chicken have
nails that look just like feathers don't
ask why you must know it's chicken claws
mine is beautiful and not just fired
about like there's this misplaced unless
everything's about to turn into TNT then
I retract it's it's very very subtle
yeah oh no mines turning ng that was
pretty anticlimactic
Wow oh my god is the top that's written
off ripped off of Bonnie from the five
nights at Freddy's 2 preview you
remember did he's get a preview image
yes here this front of his face ripped
off this is it wow you're fired
we wanted to keep that one zombie your
unfired Bobby you're fired you guys
ruined my Freddy fazbear statue for no
apparent reason
well there was many apparent reason
that explosion was terrible a nuclear
crater in the ground there's no mushroom
cloud this is not your best work
there's a little bit of a mushroom left
here oh very funny wait very bad world
is happening over there
what the hell well that's not the thing
okay oh well I guess we're not getting
an explosion okay okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching Bob and
Wade thank you for joining me on this
sad adventure thank you guys make sure
you check out Vox Populi I'll do that
and you know you know Tom B's really
upgraded his server recently yeah look
at that it was like real time I did wow
that was awesome
I really appreciate okay that's good
enough for me
bye everybody
guys guys